When you think of the SCP Foundation, you
probably think of the organization being primarily
based in the United States.
After all, many of the anomalies we cover
here on SCP Explained happen to take place
in America, so it’s easy to lose sight of
the bigger picture.
The fact of the matter is that the anomalous
is not just confined to the United States,
and if it were, the Foundation would have
a much easier time doing its job than it actually
does.
Unfortunately for the Foundation, it’s not
just the U.S that they have to focus their
efforts on, it’s the entire world.
That’s right, no matter where you are on
earth, no matter how far you travel the threat
of being the victim to an unsuspecting anomalous
incident remains the same.
Even on your family vacation to Disney World.
Of course, the Foundation’s mission is massively
expensive too, with each object requiring
not only significant resources to capture,
but even more to effectively contain and study
over a long period of time.
And then you have the utilities of each site,
keeping the power on and the water running.
Or what about actually paying the hard-working
SCP personnel who put their lives on the line
every day?
How about keeping global reconnaissance as
a watchful eye in case talk of any unnatural
incidents start making the rounds in the ordinary
world?
What about maintaining a standing army of
trained task force operatives, far deadlier
than any other military force on the planet?
Resources to cover-up events as soon as they
happen?
Field agents?
Database expenses?
It’s unimaginable to think of the costs
of operating the Foundation in one country,
let alone on a global scale.
So, how do they manage this heavy responsibility?
How does the SCP Foundation divide up its
resources accordingly, as well as raise enough
money to continue operating?
Think about it, if you were an organization
having to cover the entire globe in service
of protecting humanity from the anomalous,
what would be the best way of managing your
resources?
First, you’d make sure you were backed by
the richest of the rich, who could use some
of their personal wealth to fund your goals.
Well, that’s the Overseer Council, the group
at the top of the Foundation composed of some
of the most affluent and wealthy individuals
in the world.
Second, you’d make sure you had a means
of generating revenue.
The Foundation can’t exactly open itself
for donations from the public, and it can’t
issue taxes, but it can have others do that
for them.
Cover-up businesses and sourcing funding from
the governments of the world, either legitimately
or through blackmailing, are two surefire
ways to keep the cash flowing endlessly.
Who knows how many fortune 500 companies are
actually owned by the Foundation?
There’s a lot of money in the world to go
around, but someone needs to capitalize on
it in order to get it.
But the most important way to manage global
resources is decentralization.
Remember what we said about the perception
of the Foundation being U.S based?
Well, it’s true that the Foundation had
its origins in the United States, and the
country is the center of a large number of
containment efforts, but the english speaking
branch of the Foundation is far from the only
one.
Allow us to introduce International Branches,
or -INT, for short.
The Foundation likes to codify its various
branches based on the majority language spoken
there, so the English speaking branch would
cover nations such as the United States, Canada,
and parts of Europe.
While in regions where Chinese is spoken,
the Chinese branch presides over the territory.
Truly, the containment of the anomalous is
a global effort, with at least one Foundation
site located in each country.
Africa, India, Japan, Latin America.
There isn’t a part of the world that the
Foundation doesn’t have covered, and for
good reason too.
Anomalous objects can be discovered anywhere
and everywhere.
Having locations near all major population
centers isn’t just a luxury of having unlimited
funding, it's the very thing that necessitates
such funding.
And with International branches adhering to
their own policies, holding their own personnel,
and speaking their own languages, it should
come as no surprise that they have their own
database of SCP objects too.
That’s right, each branch has an archive
of files of their own, written based on objects
contained in their respective country.
Imagine being the guy who’s just finishing
reading all of the files currently existing
in the English database, when you realize
you then have to drudge through several more
databases filled with thousands upon thousands
of files just to be the completionist your
heart wants you to be.
It’s a time consuming task, but that’s
what we’re here for, and today we’re going
to boost your own international database with
coverage of SCP-007-INT, an anomaly sourced
from the Foundation’s global database!
It all started in Massarosa, Italy.
A medium-sized town located just outside Pisa.
It’s not famous for much, well, outside
of hosting the annual Massarosa international
piano competition, which we should remind
you that we’re all very excited about this
year considering Dr. Clef himself has decided
he’d enter.
But enough about Agent Ukulele's wild pianist
skills, let’s get back to the story at hand.
A contingent of Mobile Task Force operatives
sourced from a squad dubbed “Smoking Anomalous
Snakes”, who belonged to the Foundation’s
Italian branch, were stationed in the town
for the past week.
Given that Massarosa is smaller than the average
city, with a population numbering just over
22,000, these operatives had to take extra
precaution as to not give away their presence.
In a town where everyone knows everyone, a
gaggle of unfamiliar faces making their way
through could set off proverbial alarms in
the local population.
The Foundation operatives were there for a
single purpose - to source the production
of anomalous weaponry rumored to be occurring
throughout the region.
Now, why is this a problem in the first place?
As technology advances, war changes along
with it, sometimes necessitating the need
for more efficient weapons and inspiring their
development.
Spears to deal with invading tribes on land.
Horses and chariots to rush those with spears.
Bows and arrows to combat horses.
War has always made use of new technology
to make combat more efficient and deadly.
And anomalous weaponry is no different.
After all, not every paranormal organization
holds the same ethos as the Foundation’s
Secure, Contain, Protect mentality.
There are many groups of interest, such as
the dreaded Chaos Insurgency or the Foundation’s
greatest rival, the Global Occult Coalition,
that would be more than happy to utilize research
into the anomalous for military purposes.
And who can blame them?
With anomalous weaponry, situations can be
resolved and enemies eradicated easier and
deadlier than ever before.
Up against a world that doesn’t abide by
their mission, even the Foundation is forced
to utilize anomalous weaponry, albeit on a
smaller scale.
Take Task Force Alpha-9 “Last Hope”, a
squad made up entirely of SCP objects, such
as SCP-105, Iris Thompson, and SCP-4494, the
world’s greatest arbiter of vigilante justice,
otherwise known as The Spectre.
Even Mobile Task Forces, such as Samsara,
a group of heavily augmented cybernetic super-soldiers,
make use of anomalous weaponry to further
advance their efficiency on the field.
After all, Task Forces spend their time combating
anomalies in the field, it only makes sense
to fight fire with fire, so to speak.
Third party sellers and producers of anomalous
weaponry often provide the technology to established
groups of interest, so the Foundation getting
the jump on a distribution center in Massarosa,
Italy was a strategic move on the part of
the Foundation.
They weren’t sure of the exact details,
but their sources tipped them off about a
gang of fascist, neo-Nazis in the area working
on supplying anomalous weaponry to the criminal
underworld.
Its bad enough that the trigger-happy radicals
at the Chaos Insurgency have access to anomalous
means of destruction, imagine if every two-bit
gangster and minor criminal had their hands
on something as deadly as an SCP object, and
they could acquire even more powerful equipment
if they wanted.
If the fascists made their money, who knows
where their anomalous weaponry would wind
up?
The Foundation wasn’t sure what they were
manufacturing, but they were positive that
it wasn’t good.
Their source explicitly described it as a
weapon that could change the course of war
as they understood it, a living, breathing
shield.
Naturally, the Foundation was just as interested
in potentially finding a purpose for this
mystery weapon as they were in taking it out
of the hands of the black market suppliers.
What uses could it hold in the field?
Could it provide an extra layer of protection
for the Foundation’s operatives?
The operatives were compiled from a vanguard
and reconnaissance team, and were the only
ones the resource strained Italian branch
had available for the job.
They spent days combing through the town until
they stumbled upon what they believed to be
a hideout for the gang.
While attempting to investigate, a mysterious
man ran out in front of the team, darting
towards them from across the street.
The team went to shoot, but hesitated after
realizing that the man was accompanied by
a mysterious silver balloon-like entity ominously
floating above his shoulder.
Not only that, but he was wearing a full suit
of protective equipment, almost like a bee
keeper’s suit.
The operatives opened fire at the unidentified
target, but before their bullets could make
contact, the silver balloon began bubbling,
and spread itself across the man’s body,
like a protective sheet.
It was then that they knew they found their
living shield.
The bullets slid right off of the man, hitting
the liquid covering him and immediately being
negated by its anomalous properties.
Then, before the team could react, the liquid
shot forward, detaching from the man’s body
and latching onto a Foundation operative.
The silver gel began to writhe and constrict,
attempting to absorb the operative through
his protective gear.
In a quick executive decision, the team lead
made the choice to put the operative, who
was in the midst of being absorbed by the
gel, out of his misery.
After all, they couldn’t take risks when
dealing with an unknown anomaly, especially
one that they already knew was being utilized
as a deadly weapon.
As soon as the body dropped dead, both the
liquid and the gang member took off through
the streets, and the Foundation gave pursuit.
The Foundation chased the man through the
narrow, maze-like streets of the town, with
the silver liquid tailing after them and attempting
to absorb even more operatives.
Thankfully, the gel wasn’t fast.
The man, however, was another story.
The operatives chased and chased, indiscriminately
unloading a salvo of bullets into the general
area.
A few struck, puncturing the man’s skin
and causing him to bleed.
Following the trail of blood, the Foundation
was able to corner him into a street alley.
But then, all of a sudden, the gel burst through
the concrete wall the man was backed up against,
the anomaly now larger than ever.
The goo reconnected with the man, shielding
him from the Foundation’s firepower and
allowing him to run away and escape.
The Foundation briefly retreated and reconvened
with their superiors to try to find the best
strategy to move forward.
They then took to the streets again, searching
for the man and any trace of the anomaly.
They found bits of the liquid strewn through
the streets, squirming and writhing.
Unlike the first batch, these bits were able
to be neutralized via regular bullets.
Their search eventually bore fruit, and they
found the man patching himself up in a nearby
cellar.
He had a briefcase, and the area around him
seemed to be a type of laboratory.
Still, they were unable to find the silver
balloon anomaly.
The operatives with weapons drawn, attempted
to speak with the man, but he lashed out and
shot at the them, prompting them to shoot
back, immediately killing him.
They weren’t able to get much information
from him, but it was an act of self defense.
The Foundation, now with their only source
of information gone, resorted to looking through
the rest of the basement.
They found a series of documents held inside
the room, all written in Italian.
They also found a tunnel leading outside the
town, and a small cart that was intended to
be used to transport cylinders containing
the silver liquid out of Massarosa.
The Foundation was very quick to stop this
anomaly from getting out on the black market,
as it seemed like this was a distribution
and testing center.
But with the man dead and the gel contained,
they realized their mission was complete,
and collected all remaining documents and
traces of the silver liquid anomaly.
In a joint effort between the Italian and
Lusophone branches, the liquid was transported
to Brazil for further research and classified
as SCP-007-INT.
The Lusophone branch’s board of superintendents
had made the decision earlier that SCP-007-INT
held historical and research significance
for the two branches, as some of the task
force members that aided in the capture of
the anomaly were sourced from Brazil.
The documents were shared between both branches,
and chemical research on the object was conducted.
Immediately, the Foundation discovered the
reason why the liquid responded so quickly
to the man who was distributing it, and why
it works perfectly as a living shield.
SCP-007-INT is sentient, and capable of recognizing
patterns and portraying emotion, albeit to
small degrees.
Research into SCP-007-INT’s composition
and responses to stimuli in a lab environment
continued, but one researcher from the Italian
branch noted that this wasn’t the first
time they had encountered an anomaly like
this.
When dealing with a group of organizations
known as the Fascist Council of the Occult,
the Foundation discovered a heavily redacted
and secret anomalous weapon with certain properties
similar to SCP-007-INT.
While the details of this weapon were lost
to the database and above our clearance level,
we can assume that due to the nazi connection
between the man distributing the liquid and
the fascist council of the occult, that portions
of SCP-007-INT managed to make their way to
the black market and proliferate the criminal
underworld.
But when all the research was said and done,
what was SCP-007-INT?
The studies were conducted as a joint operation
between the two branches, and as a result,
allowed for a significant amount of testing.
Researchers found that the gel was adaptable,
durable, and intelligent to a certain degree.
But they also discovered that their data was
incredibly similar to another anomaly in their
database, recorded by the Lusophone branch’s
predecessor, the Scientific Academy of the
Anomalous.
You see, the Foundation hasn’t been around
forever.
Before it, the anomalous containment world
was decentralized and composed of tinier organizations,
and this was one of them.
As it turns out, this organization recorded
data remarkably similar to SCP-007-INT, but
the details of the research was lost due to
an incident involving rogue agents defecting
from the organization, think the Chaos Insurgency,
but before them too.
The two instances of this anomaly were apparently
a perfect match to SCP-007-INT, and the two
branches had both contained the same anomaly,
across decades, without being aware that the
other had done it.
While the documents were lost when the defecting
agents broke away from the Academy, researchers
theorized that they either defected into or
sold information about the anomaly to the
Fascist Council, who were able to improve
the liquid and turn it into a formidable,
military grade weapon.
Still, the experiments with SCP-007-INT proved
to be a success.
The anomaly’s sapience allowed it to form
a bond with its host, protecting and showing
the desire to comfort them if need be.
What a nice little hunk of deadly gunk, right?
But then, just as the branches were about
to give up on finding the Academy’s old
documentation for SCP-007-INT, they happened
to discover it.
The anomaly was given the codename “Project
Mel”.
This initial research found that the anomaly
was incredibly adaptive, as seen below:
“Instance α is the most belligerent case
of SCP-007-INT.
It prefers being involved in combat-oriented
exercises and watching martial performances.
α has demonstrated a certain degree of infatuation
to the party with, in its conception, the
best performance by using its pseudopods in
attempts to imitate some executed movements
for the respective party to see.”
“Instance β is an exemplary case of personality.
I have witnessed β adducting a stuffed penguin,
irresponsibly given by one of its Operators
— to demonstrate affection; β also displayed
excitement when presented with pictures of
penguins.
An extraordinary situation involving β happened
when it parted itself; its copy assumed the
form of a penguin, which β proceeded to care
for in the likeness of an animal companion.
β protected and guided the copy through the
training course until the spontaneous expiration
thereof.”
“Instance γ possesses a particularly high
physical intelligence.
It is expressly competent in solving movement-related
problematics such as obstacle courses involving
the manipulation of sensitive objects and
complex movement and transformation patterns.
Interestingly, γ has been seen reacting to
music by dancing to the respective rhythm.”
This original documentation proved to be valuable
to the Foundation, as it provided further
information on what occurred when SCP-007-INT
was stolen from its original location and
placed into the hands of the Fascist Council.
On December 25th, 1972, several security breaches
across the Academy occurred, as sleeper agents
of the Council stole various anomalous assets
from storehouses and vaults across the country.
For two hours, the group of six rogue individuals
took what they could, smuggling the objects
away from the organization for the purposes
of using and selling them to the highest bidder.
Objects stolen included “Project Mel”,
several prototype prosthetics, and various
other pieces of high-security Academy documentation.
The Foundation also discovered that these
sleeper agents within the Academy were students,
researchers, and operatives who had been working
with the organization for years, sometimes
decades.
Given their history, it's possible they may
have been coerced rather than them being outright
agents of the fascist council of the occult.
Unfortunately, all of them expired during
the interrogation procedures, and only one
survived, captured by the Academy via suspended
animation, though their whereabouts in the
present day are unknown.
It’s unknown if the Foundation has seen
the last of SCP-007-INT, or if samples of
the deadly, adaptive living shield are still
lurking in the anomalous criminal underworld.
Regardless, whoever possesses SCP-007-INT
is surely to be a formidable force for anyone
to go up against.
Now go check out “SCP-354 - The Red Pool”
and “SCP-006 - Fountain of Youth” for
more anomalous liquids contained by the SCP
Foundation!